>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Travis Painter: Hello!
I'll tell you, it's
not often that we get
to have Lady Gaga
blaring in this room.
So good evening,
and happy pride.
[ Cheering ]
As I was walking around before
we started, I had talked
to a couple of people, and found
out that somebody even came here
for their birthday today.
So happy birthday to Ellie
up front in the front row.
[ Cheering ]
On behalf of the Library, and
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden,
we want to welcome you guys to
the Library of Congress tonight.
My name is Travis Painter,
and I'm the Chairman
of the Library's LGBTQ+,
an employee organization,
what's called LC Globe.
And LC Globe was organized 24
years ago, and we are proud
to represent the
Library's LGBTQ+ employees.
We have a lot of different
programs that we've put on,
different cultural programs,
different educational programs,
to highlight the
collections that we have
that represent the LGBTQ
contribution to American society
and what we do every day here
at the Library of Congress.
We're eager tonight
to co-host an event
with an award-winning author.
She is the writer
of several novels,
including the best seller, Simon
vs. The Homo Sapiens Agenda.
And that was adapted to a film
that became a box
office hit, Love, Simon.
So we're honored to have
Becky Albertalli here tonight.
We're eager to hear
her talk about Simon
and the entire universe
that she has created
around these unforgettable
characters.
So tonight, we will learn more
about her literary inspirations,
her new books that are
coming out, and much more.
We want to thank
some of our partners
for making tonight
such a success.
We have the Congressional CSA,
Congressional Staff Association;
GLASS, which is the Senate LGBTQ
employee organization, as well.
And, of course, the
organizers of Capital Pride.
We want to encourage
you to visit.
We have a display that
was set up in the front.
A lot of you probably
saw that when we came in.
At the library, we have
such a vast collection.
We have iconic poetry
from Whit Waltman.
Excuse me.
Walt Whitman.
To the manuscripts
of the founder
of the LGBTQ activism
here, Frank Kameny.
And we have the papers of
Jonathan Larson, who wrote Rent.
And you can see the
math that he did to come
up with 525,600 minutes.
So you're welcome.
That will be in your head
the rest of the night.
Yeah, so we have all of these
amazing collections here.
And you can see some of them out
in the foyer on your way out.
But now to talk about tonight's
event and why we're here,
after the presentation
outside, you can buy the book
and have Becky sign it for you.
And, again, she's an
award-winning writer.
She's the author of
three best-selling books;
Simon vs. The Homo
Sapiens Agenda,
The Upside of Unrequited,
and Leah on the Offbeat.
She has a new book scheduled
to come out this October,
and I know a lot of you
are excited to read that.
Becky has a gift of
believably writing
in the voice of a teenager.
One reviewer said, "are
you absolutely certain
that Becky Albertalli
didn't steal the diary
of a hilariously
observant teenage boy?"
So tonight, Becky will be
interviewed by the Library
of Congress's Chief
Communications Officer,
Roswell Encina, who,
like many of you,
have fallen for Simon
and his friends.
So now, please help me welcome
to the stage Becky Albertalli.
[ Music ]
>> Roswell Encina: Good evening,
everyone, and thank you, Travis,
for that wonderful introduction.
And welcome, Becky.
>> Becky Albertalli: Thank
you so much for having me.
This is an amazing
crowd, oh my gosh.
>> Roswell Encina: It's like
a little homecoming for you.
I understand you used to
live here in Washington.
>> Becky Albertalli:
Yeah, this is-- yeah.
And I think a lot of my
friends are out here.
>> Roswell Encina: You don't
mind if we share the story
of who you bumped into when
you arrived in Washington.
It's such a small world.
>> Becky Albertalli:
Oh, yeah, no.
Yeah, you know, so I really
got here not too long before
the event.
It's been kind of
a whirlwind trip.
I checked into my hotel,
walked outside, and five--
less than five minutes later,
I bumped into my prom date
from high school, who
had just moved back here
from Atlanta, which
is so awesome.
>> Roswell Encina:
Well, let's talk Simon.
So I have to be honest, you
know, after I read the book,
after I saw the movie, there
was a part of me that kind
of fantasized that I
was a teenage boy again
and had a teenage
boyfriend via e-mail.
So I'm guessing you
hear this a lot.
So you hear this a lot from
probably grown men like me, or,
you know, teenagers that this
book relate to them a lot.
What did you tap into,
and how did you get
into the psych of
a 16-year-old boy?
>> Becky Albertalli: Thank you.
I'm really glad it
worked for you.
And, you know, I'm always
glad when the book works
for somebody, because
it's never a guarantee.
I think when I wrote this
book, and with all of my books,
I really tried to
I guess like tap
into that individual
character's head.
And it's kind of a deep dive.
So, you know, when I wrote
Simon, I mean like, I was,
I was like living in Simon.
And I didn't tell anybody.
I think I told maybe like
one or two people after I was
like almost done drafting it.
I was very, very
private about it.
But like I carried this
kid with me everywhere.
And I think, you know, my
books, all of the, you know,
have a lot of me in them.
Simon-- I get the question
a lot, like what was it
like writing about a character
who is so different from you?
I'm like, I haven't done
it yet, so I don't know.
>> Roswell Encina:
I mean, but you--
it's hard enough
being a teenager.
A normal straight
teenager has a lot of acts.
A gay teenager has
a whole lot more.
And you describe it very well.
As Travis said in
the introduction,
it's like you're writing
from a teenage boy's diary.
What was your basis?
Who inspired you?
Where did Simon come from?
>> Becky Albertalli:
I actually read a lot
of teenage boys-- no, I did not.
No, I did not.
I feel like when
you're a psychologist,
you cannot say that.
That's actually the first thing
I always want to say is a lot
of people know I used
to be a psychologist.
And so it's really, really
important I feel like to lead
with the fact that Simon is
not based on anybody I work
with because, you know, my
priority, no matter what,
even as an author, even though
I haven't practiced psychology
in years, like my priority
is making sure the clients
that I work with
don't feel vulnerable.
So I don't touch that.
You know, I think
sometimes people I know
from real life make
their way into the books.
Sometimes I don't realize
it until afterwards.
And sometimes like I
find myself like popping
up in the book in
unexpected places.
Like I remember there
was this moment.
>> Roswell Encina: Do
you like Oreos then?
>> Becky Albertalli:
Well, yeah, yeah.
People are like,
well, people are like,
what is the symbolic
meaning of Oreos?
And I'm like, all right,
well, let me tell you.
Like, I really like Oreos.
That's it.
But I think there was one
moment where, you know,
I think I was describing
just like a little
like technique I used to use in
therapy sessions, which was kind
of like a bribe where I would
let-- I worked in a school,
so I would let kids like
use their social media
in therapy sessions, which
they desperately wanted to do,
because it was school and they
wanted to be on the internet,
if they would let me sit right
next to them, and we would talk
about everything
in their sessions.
And I was describing this
to like a room full
of high schoolers.
And I think I like
realized in that moment,
I'm like, I'm Simon's mom.
Like this whole time, I
thought I was the teenager,
like I thought I was cool,
and I'm not, like I'm the mom.
But she's like kind
of a cool mom.
And Jennifer Garner has like
completely made her cool.
So like I am like really,
really okay with it now.
>> Roswell Encina: She
was Sydney Bristow.
We'll talk more about
Jennifer Garner in our next.
Anyway, I swear, if
this book was around,
it would have helped me
a lot when I was 15, 16.
Back in the 80s when I was that
age, there was really nothing.
And I asked Andre
Aciman this yesterday.
Most of the characters or
any from books to movies,
every time it's a gay character,
you're either a sidekick,
either comic relief, or there's
some tremendous tragedy attached
to it.
But the beauty of
Simon is, there's none.
He, and like from Call Me by
Your Name, everybody's main kind
of big issue is just love.
And I think everybody can
relate to that, right?
>> Beck Albertalli: Yeah, you
know, and I think, I mean,
I feel strongly there's a
place for all kinds of stories,
and especially, you
know, a lot of times,
you'll find there are some
really painful stories sometimes
coming from within
the community,
and people telling their own
stories, or kind of using,
drawing upon their own
experiences in different ways.
But I think that has
been one of the things
that I think has resonated with
a lot of people about Simon.
It's just like the joy
of the love story in it.
>> Roswell Encina: And what I
like about him the most is
he doesn't make a big deal
that he's gay.
I mean, for him,
it doesn't even--
his sexuality doesn't
bother him.
So I wanted to read
something from--
actually, it's just
from page two.
It's a giant holy
box of awkwardness,
and I won't pretend I'm looking
forward to it, but it probably,
probably wouldn't be the end
of the world, not for me.
So that just kind
of sets up a scene
that it's like, oh, whatever.
Do you think this
is generational,
or depends where you
live in the country?
And I don't want to
minimize other kids' issues
of coming out, because
everyone has their own process
that they have to go through.
But I think that's what made
maybe Simon more refreshing.
Many kids could relate to it,
especially the next generation
of, you know, young gay adults.
>> Becky Albertalli: I think,
I think that's a
really good question.
I think it's really complicated,
and certainly somewhat
generational.
But it's not like, you know,
change isn't always linear.
And, you know, I
really do believe
that not only does
environment play such a role,
but it just like, it
can get, you know,
down to the specific family.
Like I really think if Simon
had a next door neighbor,
it could be a closest
family friend, you know,
and if there was a gay
kid in that family,
that kid may have a totally
different experience than Simon
for any number of reasons, some
of which is just, you know,
different people have
different comfort levels
with like sharing things,
and different types
of relationship dynamics
with their family.
So kind of in a very
like, you know, micro way,
I think those differences
are significant.
So it's really hard to
generalize and say like,
you know, because
I've had people,
and I think the way
people read the book
or experience the movie
can be very informed
by their own experiences.
So there are people
who are like,
this is exactly what it's like.
And then there have been people,
I think there was an article,
and like bless his heart,
this guy who wrote it got
like dragged on Twitter, and he
was like, everybody was like,
who is this straight
guy like saying this?
He wasn't a straight
guy who wrote it.
But he was like, he was the
one who asked the question,
like do kids really
need this film anymore?
Was it like Time Magazine?
Does anybody-- there are
people who remember that slang.
And actually like this article
did have some really interesting
critiques about like
kind of some
of the intracommunity dynamics
and like nuances within that.
But, you know, it was, I
think people really responded
to that particular question.
Like do teens really need this?
Because, I think, there
is this idea somewhat
that like we solve
like homophobia.
But that's so far from the
lived experience of so many
of my readers, which, you know,
that's just like, you know,
that's just talking about
like readers in the U.S.,
like when you think
globally, I mean,
they just like canceled the
release of Love, Simon in India.
Like people are devastated.
Like this is the
reality across the world.
It's just a lot of it has to do
with like where you were born
and who your family is, and
that can shape that experience.
>> Roswell Encina: And I
feel like young adult writers
like you really help, from John
Green to yourself, have brought
up so many issues that teens
could not really relate
to beforehand.
And so they started
reading about it.
>> Becky Albertalli: I hope so.
It's like, I don't know, that's
wonderful company to be in.
I love John Green.
Yeah, you know, it's
interesting,
because when I wrote this
book, Simon in particular,
which is my first book, which
I never thought would be
published, by the way.
It's like still very strange.
But, you know, I really thought
of it the whole time
as a love story.
And, you know, it's kind of
almost like retroactively taken
on a certain significance,
mostly because of the movie
and the studio backing and
that being kind of a moment
in the film industry, you
know, but Simon is not--
I get really squirmy sometimes.
People feel like Simon is
the first gay love story,
gay [inaudible] love story.
And I'm like, oh my
gosh, like first of all,
you're in for a treat.
Because there is a
whole like, you know,
there's like a whole
history behind it.
Like, you know, when I
wrote Simon and I was kind
of trying to, you know,
figure out how to position it
to like publishing
houses and stuff.
Like, you know, some of the
authors who are in my mind were
like David Levithan, Bill
Konigsberg, you know,
there's like Brent
Hartinger, Geography Club.
I mean, there's so many
wonderful books that, you know,
I like describe it as like,
you know, it's like standing
on the shoulders of giants.
And there's this whole
conversation, and, you know,
more and more books being
written in the space,
and it's exciting
to be a part of it.
>> Roswell Encina:
People tend to call them
that crossover appeal books when
they're just good books, right?
>> Becky Albertalli: I hope so.
I like the idea of it.
I know that like I get a
lot of people who are like,
I'm not your target age range.
Like I know I shouldn't be
reading YA, I'm like 28.
And I'm like, I'm 35, and
like I like only read YA now.
>> Roswell Encina: I'm
48, and I'm reading them.
I should say, though,
and let's talk about some
of the stuff in the book.
I really like the part that
you use the e-mail conversation
to move the story forward.
So I just kind of want
to read some parts here.
On page 59, so I'm a complete
nerd here, but we do work
at the Library, so
we're allowed to, right?
So here's one of the, I think
it's an e-mail from Simon
to Blue, from Jacques
to Blue, I should say.
So I keep thinking about the
idea of secret identities.
Do you ever feel
locked into yourself?
I'm not sure if I'm
making sense here.
I guess what I mean is
that sometimes it seems
like everyone knows
who I am except me.
That's fantastic.
Then I love how you always kind
of put pop culture
into everything.
So in one of the
e-mails, it says, P.S.,
I'm attaching a Reese's
cup to this e-mail.
I hope this is what
you had in mind.
Is this why kids are
relating to this so much,
the pop culture references, the
use of e-mail, and, you know,
how he was outed, thus, leaving
your e-mail not logged off,
and somebody else
logging into it?
I mean, these are things
that actually happen.
>> Becky Albertalli: Yeah,
you know, I don't know.
It's, I think, a very
personal experience, you know,
with Simon readers and
with readers in general,
like what's the moment in
the book that connects you
to that character, you know,
so there are a lot of people
who can relate to, you know,
Simon's thoughts
about coming out.
Believe it or not, I get like,
you would not believe how many
e-mails I get that are like,
I love this book, it has so
many Harry Potter references.
And I'm like, I get
it, yeah, like no,
I have loved books
because of that too.
Like Harry Potter,
especially, it's like so full
of Harry Potter references.
>> Roswell Encina: What are your
current pop culture obsessions?
>> Becky Albertalli: Okay, so,
well, in addition to like Love,
Simon, which is just like
embarrassing how much I love it,
and I can say that because it's
like I didn't make the movie.
I just, I've seen it 13
times, like on purpose.
Hamilton, Jeremy Hanson,
and, oh, gosh, I feel like,
I feel like I'm missing
something big.
Like what am I into?
It's not Paw Patrol
and it's not--
I'm like, it's not the things
that I actually watch the most
in my day-to-day life, which are
definitely like Power Rangers
and Paw Patrol and like
God knows what YouTube toy
unboxing videos.
Like I have two young kids.
But to the extent
that I have time for,
and I think I love the things
that like nerdy theater
teenagers like.
Am I right?
Are there any like
theater kids out here?
[ Cheering ]
>> Roswell Encina: I like how
you use diversity in your books.
And I'm not just
talking about race.
But between, you know, gay
and bisexuals, and just kids
of all shapes and
sizes are all in there,
was that a conscious
decision of yours?
>> Becky Albertalli: Yes and no.
I mean, I think to
some extent, you know,
there's just the desire to, you
know, create a world that is
as inclusive as the
world that I live in.
And, you know, I think I
get more credit for that,
for Simon, than I deserve.
The movie actually improved
upon what I did in the book.
And so that's something that
I'm really excited about,
just some of the casting
choices in the movie.
But, yeah, I think
certainly increasingly,
as I've written more and more
books, it's something I think
about with like every word that
I write, because, you know,
for better, for worse,
every book that I've written
after Simon I've written
with a very acute
awareness of my audience.
It makes it, you
know, you can get
like paralyzed by that kind of.
Like, you know, you're
like trying to write a book
with like all these sequels
reading over your shoulder.
But I think it's
really important.
And, you know, I
have been very aware
of who my Simon readers are
and who I'm hearing from.
And so, you know, I can't
imagine ever writing a book,
for example, that
doesn't have, you know,
I'm not saying the main
character is always going
to be part of the LGBTQQIAAP
community, but there's going
to be characters from the
community within my books,
because I'm not-- I can't
see myself writing a book
where all these readers who
trust me and have read my books
like feel like they don't have
a home, you know, and, you know,
feel like I am not seeing them
or I'm choosing not to see them
for the duration of
the book, you know?
And it's imperfect
because there's
so many intersections
there, and there are--
there's such a range
of experiences,
and you're never
going it be able
to capture everybody's
experience.
But to me, it's something
to strive towards,
just kind of making more
and more people feel seen.
>> Roswell Encina: You create
this whole Simon verse,
I should say.
So the sequel to Simon
is Leah on the Offbeat,
where we discover
Simon's BFF is bisexual.
Was that always your intention,
or were there hints in this book
that I completed missed it
until the new book came out?
>> Becky Albertalli: No,
it wasn't my intention.
So the only person
who's like almost
as oblivious as Simon is me.
No, because, you know, I was
like so deep in Simon's head,
to the point where there
were things that I wrote
into that book, like I
wrote that book, I wrote it,
it was there, you know, and
there were things that were
like really specific signals
that a lot of people picked
up on, like to the point where
I think people are surprised
to hear that Leah is bi
because it was there.
But Simon didn't see it.
And it took me a
minute to see it.
Like I had to be
like woken up to it.
And it's been a couple years.
It's not a decision
that I made recently.
Like people, I've seen people,
like grandstanding on Twitter
or something, being like,
she just made it that way
like because of the movie,
because of that moment
with Katherine Langford,
you know,
and Katherine Langford
makes this face
in the Halloween scene, and
that's why Becky decided.
I'm like, no, Becky talked
to Katherine Langford on set.
Like this book was already
like you know, but yeah, yeah,
so it's just, it's sort of
like the way I've seen these
characters evolved.
And I gave myself a real
gift without meaning
to by making Simon
like so clueless.
Like he's so-- things happen,
and he doesn't see them.
Like he doesn't see like five
feet in front of his face.
And he even says, and it's
not just that he's clueless
in general, which he, dear
God, is, but he, like even says
about Leah, and he's like,
he's like, I don't get her.
Like he's just like there's this
subtext with Leah that I can't
like quite like unpack
or wrap my head around.
And so like having, having the
opportunity to write a book
that kind of dove
into what the secret
of mysterious character was
thinking and feeling and going
through right under the
oblivious character's nose,
like highly recommended.
It's a blast.
I really loved it.
>> Roswell Encina: Would you
say you have produced some
of the most successful gay
main characters nowadays.
So I'm thinking you know the
wonderful responsibility you
have on yourself and how the
entire LGBTQ community is
cheering you on, and
very thankful for that.
Are you aware of how grateful
we all are for these books?
>> Becky Albertalli:
That's really nice.
Thank you.
You know, and, I
mean, I'm grateful.
I'm grateful to be a
part of the conversation.
And I think it's
really complicated,
and I think there's
things that I have come
to understand now better
than I did five years
ago when I wrote Simon.
I started writing Simon just
about exactly five years
ago in June, you know?
And, you know, I
think the conversation
in young adult literary
spaces, especially those spaces
that are concerned with
writing inclusive books.
There's discussion about
ownership of stories.
And it's not so much that
Simon is like a gay character,
but more I think that
it's a coming out story,
and who has a right
to tell that.
And it's something
that I take seriously
and I think about all the time.
And, you know, I
don't think, you know,
I was privy to those
conversations in the same way
in 2013 when I wrote it.
And, you know, and I think the
conversations themselves have
kind of moved in
interesting ways.
But I just, I try to follow it,
and, you know, it's not like--
I can't like stop the train.
I can't like unpublish the book.
And I'm really grateful
that a lot
of people have connected
with it.
But it's complicated, and that's
something that I'm really open
with with authors
who are considering
like writing outside
of their lane.
You know, you have to sit
with the fact that like
in the same day, you're going
to get e-mails from somebody
who says you changed their
life, or you saved their life.
And then you're going to
hear from somebody who says
like you shouldn't
have written this book.
You just, you have
to sit with that.
Yeah.
>> Roswell Encina: What other
YA books, or other books
that you recommend to some
LBTQ teens for them to read,
after they read, of
course, your three books?
>> Becky Albertalli: You
don't have to read mine first.
First, before I even
start naming books,
I want to give you a website,
because it's phenomenal.
It's LGBTQ Reads.
And it's curated by an
author named Dahlia Adler.
Her books, by the
way, are wonderful.
Actually, one of them
called Under the Lights is,
I would say if you
liked my books,
you're going to like that book.
And I love that site
because it's got
like really comprehensive
recommendations.
And she has like
lists that kind of go
into like what identities
are represented in the books,
which is just like
really important to a lot
of my readers I know who are
looking for representation.
I really wanted to shout out
a book that came out today.
It's a book birthday for them.
It is an adorable
book called Running
with Lions by Julian Winters.
It is-- and I feel like for
years, I've heard people talking
about like I want a sports
romance, but like a gay one,
and this is, I feel
like this is that book,
but like so like
beautifully executed.
Like I don't even like
sports, but I love this book.
I was just like,
it's like, it's just,
it's a really subversive book
in the sense that this is a book
about a soccer team, and the
coach has very deliberately
decided to make this team
a safe space for this group
of kids who, you know, they
represent a range of identities
and experiences, and it's a
love story, and it's adorable.
So that book came out today.
I recommend looking it up.
And then-- and I could
also go on all night.
But another-- this is an author
whose birthday was today.
So I'm just going to stick
to the birthday theme,
and then I'll leave you guys
to the website, LGBTQ Reads.
So have any of you guys
heard of Adam Silvera?
[ Cheering ]
I should have filmed that.
I feel like if you've heard
of me, you've probably heard
of Adam Silvera, because
he co-wrote my next book.
Like we wrote together.
But it's his actual
birthday today.
And he has three books
that are out now.
And every single one of
them is absolutely amazing.
His books are sad.
So just, so know that, and like
when you plan your reading
schedule, like read Adam's books
and then read Running
with Lions,
or however best you need
to like organize it.
But his books are called
More Happy Than Not,
History Is All You Left Me,
and if you weren't convinced
that his books are sad,
They Both Die at the End,
which is not a spoiler,
but it's like,
like don't like get your
hopes up for them not to die.
Like they both die at the end.
>> Roswell Encina: But
you brought up Adam,
and I know the new
book coming out,
you're co-writing it
with him in October.
I was going to ask,
this was supposed
to be your last question,
but we'll talk
about the movie first.
But could you give us a preview
of this book coming
out in October?
>> Becky Albertalli: Sure,
this is my favorite
thing to talk about.
Yeah, I am so excited.
So this book, What If It's
Us is like the book that Adam
and I have like said
for years, since 2014,
since before we ever met
in-person, we have been like,
we should write this book.
And then we did.
I like can't believe we did.
It's a book that's
coming out in October.
And it's like, well,
it's definitely, by far,
the most fun writing
experience I've ever had.
I just like really recommend
writing books with Adam Silvera.
Like, yeah, not just
because you only have
to write half the book.
So it's about these two
boys named Arthur and Ben.
And Arthur is this
kind of like wide-eyed
like Broadway geek from Georgia.
If you look at the cover,
there's a tall one
and a short one.
He's the short Jewish
one from Georgia.
I wrote Arthur.
And then Ben is like this kind
of more cynical [inaudible] you
know, born and bred New Yorker.
He's this Puerto Rican kid.
He's stuck in summer school.
He's just had a breakup.
And like, you know, so like
Adam's character Ben is
like so pissed at the universe.
Now he just feels like
the universe is trying
to like screw him over.
And my guy, Arthur, is
like, I'm in New York.
Everything I know
about New York comes
from like Broadway and movies.
So he's like, obviously huge
things are going to happen
for me and my life is like
pretty much going to be
like a musical, and I'm probably
going to meet my soul mate.
And so like, you know, this
is sort of where they are
when they meet each
other in a post office.
And like Adam's character
is like shipping stuff back
to his ex-boyfriend, and my
character is like, he's cute,
and I'm going to follow
him to the post office.
>> Roswell Encina: Is that
their big meet-cute is
at the post office?
>> Becky Albertalli:
That's the big meet-cute
in the post office.
And then, yeah, so the gist of
it is like they get separated
and they find each other again.
But it's not like serendipity.
It's more like they find each
other again relatively quickly,
because, you know,
Arthur works very hard.
And then, you know, I think
most of the book is them kind
of dealing with-- well,
they have just very
different world views.
And then also, you know, their
reality of this like friendship
and relationship, you know,
when it's like put up next
to just the expectations
that they have, you know,
it's complicated for both of
them for different reasons.
>> Roswell Encina: So it
comes out October what?
>> Becky Albertalli: It
comes out October 9th.
>> Roswell Encina: So mark
your calendars, everyone.
Why don't we talk
about the movie?
Do you remember the time
you got, I'm not sure
if it was an e-mail or a
call, that they were going
to turn this book into a
movie, and how did that go?
>> Becky Albertalli:
I actually do,
but only because it
was very chaotic.
For the most part, you know,
like I should say like,
you know, there are these
little like steps along the way
to like making a
book into a movie.
And it's different for a
real adaptation process.
But I think in general one thing
that they tell us pretty
quickly is like all kinds
of stuff can happen,
and they're still,
they're not going make
the movie, you know?
So you, you know,
you get these calls,
and they're very exciting,
but like if you want
to know the moment when I
realized they were going
to make the movie, it was like,
I was like in the theater,
and it was like, you
know, I'm like, okay,
like yeah, that's the bleachers.
Yep, there we go, you know?
But I do remember getting the
call that Fox had optioned it.
And I was at Barnes &
Noble on a play date
with a fellow author,
Aisha Saeed.
And you should read
her book, Amal Unbound.
That's her middle grade that
just came out, and it's amazing.
And she has three little boys,
and I have two little boys,
and we were about to walk
into the parking lot in front
of Barnes & Noble in, I think
we were in Sandy Springs,
I think we were in
Simon's hometown,
and then I get this call.
And so the hero of this
story is my friend, Aisha,
who wrangled five boys, the
oldest of whom at the time was
like six, right by a parking
lot while I took the call
that Simon was going
to be optioned by Fox.
And I had no idea
what that meant.
But like, and I like
did not want my kids
to run into the parking lot.
It's hard to know what would
have happened with that call
if she hadn't been there.
>> Roswell Encina: I think
the movie perfectly kind
of adapted the heart
of the book.
But when you were told like, oh,
this guy who, you know, produces
and directs The Flash and
Arrow and Supergirl on TV,
did it ever occur to you, like,
how is he going to do this
when he's doing, you
know, superheroes on TV,
how is he going to do a nice
little fun teen romance?
>> Becky Albertalli:
Oh, he was [inaudible]
when they told me he was
like being considered
to be the director, I literally
don't remember anybody else they
were considering.
So I was like [inaudible]
because his name had already
come up earlier in the process
like with like production
companies and stuff.
So I already by then
had researched him
and knew who he was.
One of the things that
stood out is he had worked
on Dawson's Creek, and like, I
feel like I'm going to say this
and you're going to know
exactly how old I am,
except I already told you.
Like Dawson's Creek was like my
obsession when I was a teenager.
But I think more importantly,
like the first time I ever
saw two boys kiss was Jack
on Dawson's Creek.
And I found out later that
Greg Berlanti is the reason
that kiss happened.
Like he was writing for
the show at the time.
And I believe he like, he
threatened to like quit
if they cut that scene,
and they put it in.
And so like Greg Berlanti has
always been pushing boundaries
in that way.
And he's somebody who cares a
lot about the representation.
And he's also just like it was
very much a passion project
for him.
That was clear like
from the beginning.
>> Roswell Encina: How
do you feel about some
of the I guess stuff that
was edited out of the book
that were not in the movie?
There's no Alice.
What happened to Alice?
>> Becky Albertalli:
Alice, I know.
>> Roswell Encina: She went to
college and never came back.
>> Becky Albertalli:
She never came back.
I know. Yeah, Wesleyan
will do that.
But, yeah, I love Wesleyan.
I went to Wesleyan, guys.
[ Inaudible ]
But, yeah, Alice,
yeah, you know,
Alice was in an earlier
version of the script,
and I think it was just
one of those things.
You know, in general, I tried to
be kind of like, not hands-off,
but I didn't want to like be
hovering too much during the
screenwriting process because
they got a screenwriter, and,
you know, there's
definitely an element
of like they needed the space
to tell the story their own way.
And then, you know, just one
of the things with, you know,
just even condensing the
material from a novel to a film,
like a lot of things have to
be like cut or streamlined,
and Alice is a pretty-- I
mean, she's like, you know,
she doesn't live at home
most of the time, you know?
She was always kind of
on the chopping block.
I just didn't know it.
>> Roswell Encina: Another
big thing that's missing
from the movie is
the big gay bar scene
from the deleted scenes
that I saw this afternoon.
It starts off actually with
that weird awkward conversation
between Nick and Simon
before they go to the bar.
Why do you think that was
removed from the finished movie?
>> Becky Albertalli: Oh, I
think I actually know this.
>> Roswell Encina: Because
Colton Haynes was in the--
>> Becky Albertalli: I
know, Colton Haynes was--
yeah, no, I think--
oh, and actually,
has anybody seen the
deleted scene yet?
>> Yeah.
>> Becky Albertalli: Okay,
a couple of you have?
So you know there's like a
guy who like walks up to Nick.
Not Nick Robinson, but like
George Lindberg's [phonetic]
Nick, Nick the character,
like just for a split second.
That's another-- him
and Colton Haynes
and Greg Berlanti
are like all friends.
There's likes something.
I don't know.
And the reason that they
changed that character's name
to like Kevin was
because I think
that guy is named Kevin
like in real life.
So I think, I don't know,
basically, like this is like,
this is a really,
like Greg didn't want
to cut his buddies, you know?
But this is one of those
like kill your darlings things
because, you know, once,
in the big picture, like once
it was all together with kind
of these scenes as
the movie was kind
of already getting
momentum towards the end,
I think what they found is
it was such a long scene,
and it just, it kind of broke
up the momentum they
were trying to achieve.
It's just like one of
those filmmaker things
that I wouldn't have necessarily
been able to like catch
if I went in the editing room.
But I definitely get that.
I'm really excited
about the deleted scene.
I hadn't seen it until
like it came out digitally,
and like I bought it
and like watched it.
>> Roswell Encina: But they
made up for it, I should say.
There's one scene in the
movie that's not in the book.
It's that big scene with
Jennifer Garner and Simon.
I rewatched it this afternoon.
I was telling some of my
friends I started tearing
up in my office.
I was thinking, what
is wrong with me?
>> Becky Albertalli: Well,
you know, whose idea that was.
>> Roswell Encina: Whose was it?
>> Becky Albertalli:
Jennifer Garner's idea.
It was Jennifer.
Yeah, so like, yeah, that wasn't
in the first version
of the script I saw.
And like Jennifer, I think
she like met with Greg
and she was like, I want a
scene-- and it wasn't like--
I swear to God, like
I promise it's not
like she wanted more scene time.
Like she had other scenes
like in the earlier
version, you know?
So it wasn't about
how much screen time.
It was like she wanted
that moment.
And I think she wanted
it because she's a mom.
And like I've heard
her talk about this.
She's like, she's like, yeah, I
wanted to be the one to say it.
Like, she's like, I wanted
these lines to like be
out in the universe, and
I wanted them to come
from my mouth, and
like that's-- yeah.
>> Roswell Encina: Some
of the things she said,
and I was typing
this up very fast
when I was watching
it again, she says,
"I need you to hear this.
You are still you, Simon."
Then she goes on later, says,
"you get to exhale now, Simon.
You get to be more you."
I mean, it's very reminiscent
of the father from Call Me
By Your Name, and
this is kind of like,
it's equivalent in this movie.
It does make you tear up.
And, of course, right after it
is the scene with Josh Duhamel
in a father and son moment.
And I think that's what really
resonates with a lot of kids.
Maybe they're hoping that
their parents will be exactly,
will respond the same way.
>> Becky Albertalli:
That's what I'm hearing.
And, you know, what's
interesting,
I'm hearing from a lot
of kids, and the word
that people really
connecting with is exhale.
I've even like written
that in my handwriting
for people's tattoos, like
more than one, more than one,
which I'm very honored
by, because, oops, sorry,
because it's not my line.
Because like I love it.
The one that like really hit me
in the mom bone, so-to-speak,
is when she says like, you know,
you deserve everything you want.
And then there's like a moment
where she like kisses him
on the head, and she's like,
"my boy," and stuff, so like,
I don't know, one of the things
I really love about that scene,
about the movie in
general, is that, you know,
we all have different access
points to these moments,
you know, so I was on set
when that scene was filmed,
and like bawling like
throughout the entire thing.
So was everybody.
Like there were like
reporters there that day.
Fox executives were there.
It was a mess.
But like I, like yeah,
like she starts kisses him
on the head, and
that's it for me.
I'm done. I'm like,
I like, yeah.
>> Roswell Encina: Speaking
of you being on set,
most of you probably don't
know that you're in the movie.
>> Becky Albertalli:
I'm in the movie, yeah.
>> Roswell Encina:
Could you tell them
where you are in the movie?
>> Becky Albertalli:
This is really classy.
All of my author
friends who have movies,
have these like really like
poignant moments or something.
Like my friend [inaudible]
is like in everything,
it's like walking on a beach
with your family, you know?
I'm drunk at a Halloween party.
[ Laughter ]
>> Roswell Encina: But do
we get to see your face?
>> Becky Albertalli:
No, because I'm too old,
and they put a mask on me.
[ Laughter ]
You get to see my mask.
I'm a bunny, and I'm drinking.
But it's really because there's
like they fill those things
with water, and I was nervous,
so I'm like, you
know what I mean?
Yeah, it was, you know,
it was one of those things
where like I was supposed
to have a certain role
in the carnival scene, but
because of the weather,
they switched the days of
the filming, and then I was
on book tour, and then
it was like, well,
if you're having a
cameo, it's going to be
in the Halloween scene,
and you can't be a teacher,
because even [inaudible]
is not that nerdy.
And so, so yeah, so I meant
to say that I was kind
of like the mid-30s, you
know, alumna of the school
who provided the
alcohol, you know?
>> Roswell Encina: I
think we get arrested
in Georgia for that, right?
>> Becky Albertalli:
I think so, yeah.
But that was, you know,
not me personally,
but, I mean, my role.
And Adam Silvera was also in
that role, but he was actually
like a pink unicorn
with an emoji mask.
So it was like really nuances,
just a really incredible
portrayal
of the pink unicorn
with an emoji mask.
>> Roswell Encina: I think,
let's take questions
from the audience.
Do you have time for this?
>> Becky Albertalli: Yeah.
>> Roswell Encina: All
right, there's going
to be some microphones coming
down from the aisle here.
And just raise your hand.
I'll let you.
Let's start this way.
>> Over here?
>> Awesome.
Thank you.
Well, first of all, before I get
to the question, I just wanted
to thank you again for coming.
There's a lot going on in
pride in D.C. this week,
and I skipped three happy hours
because I was like,
I want to see you.
[ Applause ]
But it's to thank you.
I came out four years
ago to my family.
And when I did, it was heartfelt
and they were supporting
and loving, but they're
reading the book presently,
but they watched the movie,
and they FaceTimed me,
and they said, "we never knew."
They had no idea
what it felt like.
So thank you for
owning my story.
I trust you as an owner in this.
Thank you for doing that.
But now my question, what was
it actually like writing it?
Like I get it's fun and
exciting to be in the movie.
But what was your process,
your writing process
as you were getting into the
mindset of the character?
Where were you?
What were you thinking?
How did that go down?
>> Becky Albertalli:
First of all, thank you.
That means a lot.
So the writing part,
yeah, so you're right,
that is definitely less fun
than being in the movie.
And right now, I'm like
drafting another book,
and it's like I'm very
aware of how much less fun,
like the work I'm writing
is, than like, you know,
the red carpet and stuff.
You know, with Simon, you
know, part of it was this kind
of freedom that I can't get
back, which is the freedom
of writing a book that I didn't
think would be published.
I reread all of my
teen journals,
which are something else.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, actually, there are
parts of my teen journals
that like made it into Simon,
but like I'm not going
to say what parts.
But like word-for-word,
some of them.
You know, so I think a lot of
it is trying to kind of find
that in a 16, like 17-year-old
like part of my mind.
And then, you know, after
a certain point, like,
and this tends to happen
with the characters
that I'm writing for, is like
there are a lot of false starts,
you know, when I'm writing,
but eventually I
like find the voice.
And once I like got
Simon's voice,
then it was like
everything I wrote I got
to know him better and better.
So at this point, I feel
like I know him pretty well.
Like people will ask me random
questions about him like online
like out of nowhere,
like all kinds of things.
And I'm like, yeah, usually
I have an answer if I think
about it for a minute.
Like I know him pretty well.
So, yeah, you know, and the
process has been different
for every book, but that's sort
of where I was for that one.
>> Hi, my question is
about your new book.
Does it have an ending
more like your books
or more like Adam's books?
>> Becky Albertalli: So will
you say the last part of that?
>> Yeah, is the ending more like
your books, how your books end,
or more like how
Adam's books end?
>> Becky Albertalli: Oh,
that's a great question.
So this is a question about What
If It's Us, the co-written book.
So yeah, kind of as a reminder,
Adam is like notorious for like,
you know, like his [inaudible]
They Both Die at the End,
like these very sad books.
And I will say it is very
much a Becky and Adam ending.
>> Roswell Encina: Is it in
the Simon verse, the new book?
>> Becky Albertalli: No, it's
not in the Simon verse, yeah.
>> Hi, I just wanted to say
that when the movie came out,
I took all my friends, and they
didn't know anything about it.
But I knew.
I read the book about
a year ago.
And I got all of them
instantly obsessed.
Like we talk about
it all the time.
So more about the books.
So now that all of the Simon
verse characters are going off
to college, what will
we expect from that?
>> Becky Albertalli: From
them going off to college?
>> Yeah, like what would
the books continue to be,
if there are any more?
>> Becky Albertalli: Well,
I should say, and I think--
I feel like I'm really
sad about this,
and I know sometimes people
have been sad to hear this,
but my intention is
for Leah on the Offbeat
to be the last Simon verse book,
because it's sort of the natural
like ending point
for the series.
I get asked like a lot
to write, I mean a lot,
like several times a day,
I get asked if I'm going
to write either a sequel
from Simon's point of view,
a sequel from Blue's point
of view, or rewrite Simon
from Blue's point of
view, and those, I mean,
Leah is the last book
in the Simon verse.
But especially, especially
there's no way I would ever
touch those three.
And part of it is
because I love writing
about couples getting together.
Like that's why I write, like
to get to the like make-out.
That's how I like sit down at my
computer, and like, it's coming.
And then also I think, you
know, particularly when it comes
to the Blue point of very
much book, which is the one
that I get asked the most often,
you know, I try to be mindful
of the fact that kind
of would tap into--
and I'm trying to do
this with no spoilers--
but would tap into
an intersection
that is severely
underrepresented right now
in YA.
And because of its
connection to Simon,
it would be like a big
book right now, you know?
And that doesn't need to
be a book written by me.
>> Hi, so my friend and I,
we really love your
books and the movie.
>> Roswell Encina:
Could you stand up
and show everyone your T-shirts?
>> Okay.
>> Roswell Encina:
You're in pairs.
You should show it.
>> Becky Albertalli:
That's so great.
[ Laughter ]
>> So my question is, what made
you choose Bram to be Blue?
>> Becky Albertalli: Are we
okay with me getting into this?
Is this like kind of a--
if you're here, right,
you've seen the movie at least?
Okay, I always, I always
knew he was going to be Blue,
which is interesting,
because that makes me,
I think one the one
person who got to know him
as Bram first, you know?
And I think, you
know, my idea of him
as Bram informed my writing.
Like every e-mail I wrote
from Blue's perspective,
like I knew he was Bram, so I
was writing Bram, and, you know,
I think, you know, it's
interesting trying to think back
to like why I chose him,
because he just like, you know,
he was always-- he was Bram, he
was, you know, that nerdy like,
I don't know, who
wouldn't choose him?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, he, yeah, and
I think, you know,
some of the privileged
stuff that Simon has
to like unpack along the
way, that kind of wove itself
into the story of us, like
that wasn't necessarily
like the thing I set
out to write a book
about, but, you know.
>> Roswell Encina: We could
probably take two more
questions here.
>> Okay, so as a young
writer, and as a person really,
your writing has
really inspired me.
Who are some of the authors
that have inspired
you in your writing?
>> Becky Albertalli: So I, you
know, I think, I always say
like there are two like books,
authors, who made me want
to be a writer, or I think most
kind of influenced like the type
of writing I like to do.
One is Stephen Chbosky, like
The Perks of Being a Wallflower,
which I read when I was like 16.
And, you know, I was so in love
with Charlie, the
main character.
And I just, I felt
so connected to him.
And the other author is an
Australian YA author named
Jaclyn Moriarty.
Actually, her sister is like
really famous right now.
Like her sister is like
Liane Moriarty who writes
like women's fiction
books that are huge.
Is it like Big Little
Lies, I think?
>> Roswell Encina:
That little movie.
>> Becky Albertalli:
Yeah, well, I'm like a fan
of her sister primarily.
I actually like Liane's
books too a lot.
Yeah, no, so her sister
has written this series
of contemporary books
that, yeah, they take place
at like this high
school in Australia,
and I think what I love about
them is similar to what I love
about The Perks of Being
a Wallflower is just
like these characters feel
so real, like they feel
like actual people you could
know, and they, you know,
and it doesn't feel like,
you know, the author tried
to like infuse them
with quirks, you know,
that would be memorable.
Like it doesn't feel, like
you don't feel the craft
when you read it.
The craft is obviously there.
But I think to me that's always
been my priority as a writer is
to like make characters
who feel real.
>> All right, so, hi, so I just
want to say that last year,
Simon was like the
first book that I read
that really got me back
into reading again.
And even as like a 20-year-old
woman, I still could relate
to a lot of the things
that Simon was like feeling
from when I was like at that
point in my life where he was.
And so I just want to say that
that book kind of inspired me
to want to write my own book.
So my question is, like,
what advice would you have
for somebody who would want to
write like a YA book one day?
>> Becky Albertalli: So
I, I'm going to give kind
of my two favorite
pieces of advice.
And I'm not-- and I should
kind of give the disclaimer
that I don't have the
kind of like classical
like writing training that
a lot of authors have.
So I don't have an MFA.
I don't know like bait
sheets and things like that.
And there's things
like save the cat.
And I'm like, I love
cats, you know?
So my most important piece of
advice is to write fan fiction
because I think, because I think
it is the best writing practice
out there.
And not just because you're just
like actually like putting words
on paper, but that is really,
really important to like just be
like doing the thing,
getting used to doing it.
But, you know, I think that
you are specifically trying
to like aim for a voice, you
know, and like hit that target.
And I think like when you
start to be able to like,
to nail that with, you know,
existing characters, it becomes,
like if you're trying to do
it with original characters,
it's a different process,
but there's something
about it that feels similar.
Also, if you write like Leah
on the Offbeat, like the sequel
in the same universe, it really
is like fan fiction, you know?
Like pretty much, yeah.
And then the other thing is
maybe even more important,
which is like find your
community, you know,
whether that's like
other authors,
or just like bookish
people who are sort of going
through some aspect of
the process with you.
But like, you know, it
could be like a librarian
or something like that.
I 100% would not still
be writing were it not
for my author friends, my
little squad of author friends.
I would not be writing.
I would have quit about
two months ago or so.
I don't know.
You all know.
It's when I left Twitter.
I was done.
I was done with writing.
The reason I'm still writing
is because of my friends.
And that's not the first
time I almost quit.
So find those guys and like
hold them really tight.
>> Roswell Encina:
Speaking of your friends,
you speak very highly of Adam,
and you said it was
his birthday.
I say, why don't we
end this evening,
why don't we have the entire
audience sing happy birthday
to him, and we can
send this video
and tweet it to him, right?
>> Becky Albertalli: Wait.
My purse is in the green room.
>> Roswell Encina: Oh,
somebody could film it.
We have all these
cameras around too.
>> Becky Albertalli: Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, can we do that?
Oh, he'll love that.
Oh, this is so great.
Yeah.
>> Roswell Encina: Are
you guys game for it?
Because I'm not going
to be singing here
by myself, I should say.
>> Becky Albertalli:
I'll hold the camera.
Can I hold the camera?
Thank you so much.
And you'll just like text
this to me, and I can send it?
Thank you so much.
That's awesome.
>> Roswell Encina:
Let me stand up.
Do you want to do a
little introduction?
I'll give it to you.
I'll shoot you.
You can say it.
Then I'll-- right.
Go.
>> Becky Albertalli:
Hi, Addy [phonetic],
we are at the Library of
Congress, and a couple
of people want to say
happy birthday to you.
>> Roswell Encina:
All righty, everyone.
>> Happy birthday to you,
happy birthday to you,
happy birthday dear Adam,
happy birthday to you.
[ Applause ]
>> Roswell Encina: You could
say something and close it.
>> Becky Albertalli:
Oh, I'm still live?
>> Roswell Encina: Yes.
>> Becky Albertalli: Hi.
Happy birthday.
>> Roswell Encina: Okay,
happy birthday, Adam.
And thank you, Becky.
So that was fun.
>> Becky Albertalli:
Oh, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.